kim kardashian is revealing her at least
favorite body part and it may come as a
shock you just gotta roll with it the
beauty mogul covers allure's august
issue and inside the mag kim admits
she's had to accept the realities of one
body part well two her hands she tells
the lord quote i hate my hands they're
wrinkly and gross but don't worry kim's
okay with them now and for good reason
i've lived life and i've changed so many
diapers with these hands and i've
snuggled my babies with these hands so
i'm okay with them getting older doesn't
mean that i won't strive for perfection
but you get to a point where you're like
okay my health is more important than
anything else yeah bible it's a great
look and speaking of looks kim also sets
the record straight on the cosmetic
procedures she has and hasn't done on
the no list lip filler cheek filler and
eyelash extensions but botox is very
much on the yes list just maybe not as
much as it used to be kim shares she's
had a little bit done but it's something
she's actually chilled on yeah
kim isn't chilling on her clapback game
though at least when it comes to the
controversy surrounding her recent
weight loss she also takes a second to
respond to the criticism she got after
revealing she went to great lengths to
fit into marilyn monroe's 60 year old
dress for the met gala i had this idea
to to put it on and try it on and then
they came with like armed guards and
gloves and
i tried it on it didn't fit me and so i
looked at them and i said give me like
three weeks and i i had to lose 16
pounds
down today to
be able to fit this but i it was such a
challenge it was like a roll right i was
determined yeah many have claimed the
way kim dropped weight sets an
unattainable beauty standard but she
doesn't think so telling the mag if i'm
doing it it's attainable if i was
starving and doing it really unhealthy i
would say that of course that's not a
good message then kim calls herself an
underdog saying she thinks it's hard for
people to have compassion for her her
reasoning she says it's because she's on
a reality show feeling like i need to
work harder to show you guys that i'm
not the person you think but kim adds
that she also loves doing the show
because it gives her a chance to show
people who she really is and as momager
kris jenner explained to et back in
april the fam's new hulu show the
kardashians is giving a bigger glimpse
into their lives than ever before i love
that
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and i think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes and i
love that some of the journeys that all
of them are on and their different you
know passions before you would see
little snippets of something and now i
think the episodes are um you know
fuller of content that shows the whole
story
[Music]